with rumors swarming around potential
signings to Saudi CS2 org Falcons
potentially millions of dollars are up
for grabs for any select player willing
to make the jump but G2 has drawn A Line
in the Sand their star oper is not for
sale no matter the price
tag before we get into today's video I
just want to let you know that we got
new merch just like this shirt guess
what folks our touch grass hoodies did
so well that the suits are actually
letting us make even more dumb gamer
inspired like our new Bader zipup
hoodies made for all the real blue
collar workers out there perfect for any
environment whether it's catching fish
hanging your teammates out to dry or
just tugging on your or how about our
inspiring new onward and forward tea the
ideal shirt for the sweatiest of Gamers
so that you can slam the W key with zero
resistance and little to no chafing
teammates don't like it f them ruin
everyone's night oh and yeah we got
these blue Esports T's I forgot we made
these uh yeah they're definitely blue
and they say Esports game in style and
comfort with the score Esports drop 2
available now if you like the sound of
that and I know you did check the link
in the description below to find out
more with Counter-Strike 2's first land
out of the way we aren't just
experiencing roster Mania 2023 it's been
fullon Armageddon I don't even know
where to start kadian was benched from
the team that he captained then it
turned out he was actually betrayed by
his own comrades who now want to leave
and join astralis forcing Kaden back to
play one last tournament with the team
he was just benched from with FaZe glan
being sold the entire roster is now up
in the air with a very real chance of
twist coming back to liquid to save
North America and simple simple has been
replaced by wonderful on na'vi and will
be taking an indefinite break from
competitive CS2 and I can't play a
single ranked match past 9:00 p.m.
without facing blatant full rage hackers
okay that one isn't connected but but
the point is a lot of has happened
in like the span of less than 2 weeks
and if you're already overwhelmed strap
in because we haven't even talked about
Falcons yet team Falcons is a Saudi
Arabian Esports org that joined CS back
in 2021 they gained notoriety when they
signed an in limbo kenes along with some
other OG Frenchmen like nbk and body but
kennes is now a content creator and the
team generally hasn't done so why
are they so relevant all of a sudden
well money it's no secret that over the
last few years Saudi money has been
flooding into traditional Sports and
Esports over the last 2 years in
Counter-Strike alone the Saudi Arabian
public investment fund and its
Associated companies have purchased ESL
face it and held one of the game's
largest prize pool tournaments in the
country's capital and most recently this
Falcons team has made some not so secret
bids to buy some of the game's biggest
stars for millions of dollars to form
this super team the likes of Nico device
twist and Mony have been just some of
the names churned out of the rumor but
these became a lot more than just rumors
when the org announced that they were
signing both zic and Lars Robel the now
former coach and sports psychologist of
Vitality behind the scenes there are
even substantial reports that Falcons
are already close to taking magist from
Vitality as well making names like Nico
seem less crazy that being said there is
at least one name that has been entirely
removed from the current conversation
Mony as I said the 18-year-old star Ober
for G2 was supposedly one of the top
prospects for this new Falcons team
however in an interview with hltv about
the rumors g2's general manager said
this we are not looking to sell him at
any price since we are not in need
that's what we already told the teams
that asked us about him now this is very
interesting for a whole bunch of reasons
for starters with his wording it seems
like there are multiple teams that are
interested in buying monesy not too
surprising given the kid is nasty but it
could be that this message is not so
subtly being aimed at Falcons but what's
most important is that Mony doesn't have
a price tag tons of people online were
call calling this a bluff by G2 in order
to get even more money out of Falcons
but if you were to take it at face value
it means that G2 aren't looking for an
easy payout but long-term success in
Esports in case you haven't noticed
Esports isn't doing too hot right now G2
might be one of the more profitable orgs
out there but nothing is certain anymore
so passing up what could be a
multi-million dollar deal is no small
decision which makes me wonder if the
saying is true does everyone have a
price well when it comes to GT other
star player Nico that remains up in the
air in the same interview when asked
about Nico the GM didn't take nearly as
strong of a stance saying this Nico is
one of the greatest players who has ever
touched the game we love and live and it
would be extremely difficult to replace
him one to one many online are reading
into this vague statement as G2
suggesting that unlike Mony Nico does
have a price tag and I can see this
being a reality listen Nico is a
fantastic player but this roster has not
been produced in at the level they're
expected to be if you think about it G2
could easily build a new team around
their young star oper especially if they
get millions from selling off Nico that
being said it's important to know that
making a deal with a team like Falcons
isn't as easy as just accepting a check
there is a lot of baggage that comes
with taking Saudi money you see there
are a lot of complicated reasons as to
why Saudi Arabia has been investing so
much money into Esports recently and
while some generally view it as the
Royal Family's continued efforts to try
and diversify the nation's economy
others call it sportswashing the idea
that Saudi Arabia is attempting to clean
their image or distract from Human
Rights issues by investing billions of
dollars into traditionally Western
entertainment it's hard to criticize a
country's ethics when you're actively
taking money from them or visiting their
capital for events I'm not here to give
my opinion on how much of either is true
or even whether or not the orgs and
players in questions even give a
but it's important to know that
accepting this kind of money comes with
its own negative press but that question
keeps popping back up does everyone have
a price tag listen Falcons want to make
a super team and I have no doubt in my
mind they're going to make that happen
so when the dust of roster Mania finally
settles what is that team actually going
to look like and who's going to watch
them I I think people will watch them
but it's just like with Esports there's
so much like context of like where the
team is from regions are important right
people care where the players are from
and what countries they represent but
it's just like if it's Saudi Arabia like
the fan base isn't really popping out of
there do we care just about the players
names themselves I don't think so